on Thursday boaters across England and
Northern Ireland will be going to the
polls in the local elections and the way
things are looking
it could be a difficult night for the
Conservatives the party's new Deputy
Chair is Helen Whateley and she joins us
on the show now thank you very much for
being with us so how long have you been
in this job now how are we cause so not
very long little bit bounces on fire
with the local elections next week what
would be a good night for the concept is
I think there's no doubt that it's going
to be a difficult night for us the local
actions are going to be difficult they
come for us as a time in the election
cycle where this was always going to be
difficult so the seats are up for
election next week were the ones who
were last elected in 2015 general
election year so that tends to boost
turnout it was also a good general
election for us when we won a majority
so we were at a high point at the same
time though it's not just because of the
time in the election cycle that this is
going to be difficult for the concept I
mean Theresa May said consistently that
we'd be leaving the EU on the 29th of
March I'm still in you're absolutely
right and when I'm out on the doorstep
has I've clearly been doing a lot I hear
from time to time people saying well I'm
really frustrated with politicians as a
whole actually not just conservatives
but politicians in general because of
where we are with brexit and what I say
to them is yes I realise that I realize
how frustrated you are with Parliament
actually I'm frustrated too than MP but
these are the local elections so this is
about who you're electing to be your
local councillor who you want to provide
local services who you think it's going
to do the best job for you all those
day-to-day thing it's also a challenge
the cake the government as well isn't it
so but but yes so people will do see it
as an opportunity to kind of send a
protest under send a message so that
could well hit the figures for us but I
mean that's that's what I say and I feel
strongly for counselors and council
candidates standing for election so it's
really important to remind people that
this is about your local services and
who you want in local government yeah
let's talk about some of those
councillors shall we because they're
having a pretty difficult time of it and
one concept of council telling the
website conservative home beings are
extraordinary bad they've seriously
considered stopping count a canvassing
in case it does more harm than good and
then they went on to say over and over
again people are saying they will never
vote conserved
again I've been campaigning for several
years now and I've never encountered
this pure rage or the doorstep before I
mean have you seen some of that pure
rage well there is a lot of anger about
and you always have a mixed experience
canvassing and you have some people who
always over the years would kind of shut
the door not want to talk to you I feel
there's more anger I mean there's more
anger in politics and there was before
but on the other hand there are still
people who want to talk to us I mean
just the other day canvassing for the
first time ever I got a hug and a kiss
from from a lady but there are people
who actually don't that clarification
just to be clear might beat
inappropriate otherwise but but actually
particularly when you focus from my book
it's about the location so what are your
big flagship policies your new policies
that you've announced in the last week
or so going into this local election
well I know it says this is about local
elections it's about how your local
councils deliver for you so if you look
at conservative councils across the
country they're the ones that aren't
provide better value more money for
taxes better for recycling
well this is about the local local
government so we can talk about national
policies if you like and we can talk for
this climate change is clearly very
topical and and became to talk about
that but this is about what local
councils will do for people
the thing is though it's not that easy
as that just to always split between
national policies of local issues and
there are the reason our assess
questions because labor recently have
been pumping out it seems like a new
policy every day whether it's on SATs
whether it's on bus routes whether it's
on the environment I mean you being
outflanked here because I'm struggling
to see the same amount of new policy
generation coming from your side so I
know that labor pumping out I've seen so
when those policy announcements so of
course actually that's about what they
would like to do if they're in
government rather than a question about
local government is what these elections
are about it matters locally bus
services matter locally don't I
completely agree I really as the things
that I campaign about feel very strongly
about for instance schools and actually
would like to if we're going to talk
about schools the fact the standards are
going up in schools thanks to a
Conservative government is a really
really important message to send out
there but I mean I'll also recognize
that nationally that we have been busy
trying to do brexit and in the meantime
yes policy work is is going on but
there's only so much bandwidth but I do
think this is a good moment to not talk
about brexit folks and what local
councils do for people you've got the
European elections as well potentially
we're not definitely going to happen but
it does seem as if there's a very good
chance that we might be fighting local
elections as well and they could be even
worse potentially for the conservative
part we just want to show you a you know
a recent poll of European Parliament
voting intentions and you can see here
this is opinion research the brexit
party astonishingly given the fact that
they are so new top on 28% with labour
the Conservatives down on 14% share of
the vote I mean that looks quite
worrying doesn't it fear well I'm
thirsty I hope that we don't have those
European elections and I think and again
you hear that canvassing people saying
why are we having these elections we
voted to leave I really hope that we can
avoid them by making sure that we get
the withdrawal agreement through and we
move on and we do brexit that as for me
plan a I'd much prefer that than having
the European elections but we do know
that legally we had to had to actually
get the process going and and yes if
they do happen people I think are going
to use them as a chance to say either I
really wanted to leave and vote neither
Faraj all I really really wanted to want
to stay and actually it does reflect the
strong division in our country I hope
that we can we can move forwards and
just get on and do brexit but a sensible
moderate leaving with a deal braixen is
Theresa may a problem now on the
doorstep but actually I'd say on the
contrary more often what I've heard on
the doorstep is people saying wow it
must be really tough for the prime
minister and praising her for her
resilience and her sticking at it and
trying to get through and trying to
bring MPs together and do brexit that's
what I hear farm often and criticism I
mean do you think that she needs to set
out a clearer timetable now for her
resignation more watching it be I'm not
sure that would be helpful I think what
matters is actually the timetable and
and doing brexit that's that the number
one thing that people are concerned
about when we talk about the national
agenda and talking too much about the
leadership and the dates things of that
is a distraction and people don't want
to see politicians or anything talking
about so party politics and who's in
charge they want to just to see it first
you doing brexit and then all the other
national things that we care about
whether it's the housing situation from
the video that you showed earlier I mean
do you think what
your view because there seems to be a
bit of a debate going on in the
Conservative Party about what the
Conservative Party should be it was the
existential debate I mean does it go
down the David Cameron modernizing wing
does it go back to what many would see
is it's more traditional roots that many
local councilors will prefer me where
are you on this debate so I think I mean
this is a conversation I really welcome
because the Conservative Party is a
broad church we don't always think the
same things about everything that's been
quite clear in recent months and so to
renew this conversation as we go through
brexit
what does Britain look like after brexit
what sort of country do we want to be I
think that's really really important I
mean I'd say I come from the modernizing
side of the party and I love it when we
talk about things like no I think public
services are really important to talk to
my background was in health care so
talking about the NHS talking about
education I feel strongly about these
but also talking about opportunities for
a new generation and also actually
making the case for the important role
that businesses and entrepreneurs play
in our society and actually those both
give given new generation opportunities
and give us a strong economy to fund the
public services that we care so much
about this is a sort of conversation I
want us to be able to have okay and
earlier on the show we spoke to um in
black fur to the the SNP and he was
explaining why he didn't want to be
going to the state dinner that's been
put on for Donald Trump and I just want
to talk to you about it because you
tweeted a picture a few years ago didn't
you Donald Trump's inauguration I think
we can see it very fetching how's that
infamous picture him which got a bit a
response to social media I mean say what
what's going on it are you a Trump fan
not particularly I mean I was asked to
go along to the inauguration as a
Conservative Party representative and I
thought well that would be an
interesting thing to go along to and to
see what the mood is in the US and
actually to understand the feeling of
why people voted for President Trump and
that was really really interesting I was
sitting there out that inauguration next
people have voted for him and hearing
about how they voted him because they
felt nobody was listening to them and it
was their protest it was our way of
wanting to get heard Trump is an
individual I have mixed feelings about
and I don't like some of the things that
he said but what I recognize overall is
he is President of the United States of
America and we had to recognize the
importance of that office the importance
of America
as the country that we have such a
strong relationship with security
relationship trade relationship and
that's really important to have that
good relationship also to have
conversations about things we care about
like climate change and try and
influence President Trump to do his part
in that I mean you used to be the
Conservative Party vice chair for women
this is a man who described women as fat
pigs and slobs and it is facing
harassment allegations is that where
those mixed feelings come from I mean so
I'm still actually responsible for the
women's reso yes I don't like some of
the stuff he said about women and I
would I think that rhetoric is really
really unhelpful wrong it suggests an
attitude towards women which I have no
support for so I don't like seeing that
and and I know I want to continue my
role for women there's Adelaide in the
party making sure that we go in the
right direction on women having more
women stand for election for instance
and I'm continuing to you that my new
role is jepty chair okay and we're on
time home won't you thank you very much
for being on the program